[Musique]
bonjour bonsoir à toutes et à tous
j'espère que vous allez bien c'est HUG
pour ce nouvel épisode d'envergure pour
votre podcast hebdomadaire de scooting
on va parler cette semaine d'un joueur
five stars c'est notre c'est notre sujet
et on va parler de Ky Evans junior et
pour ça je suis avec deux monuments j'ai
avec avec moi Manu et Julien comment
vous allez les gars ça va très bien ça
va ça va s'il y a un monument ici c'est
Manu he c'est pas mais non mais tu es tu
es grandiose tu es gotesque comme disent
les jeunes mon j t'inquiète pas Kemy
Evans junior avant d'aller dans les
détails de parler de ses plats préférés
de parler de ses mensurations pour que
les gens ils aient une petite image
mentale euh du profil dont on va parler
comment est-ce que vous le décrirez pour
la NBA euh en une toute petite phrase
Manu par exemple pour moi c'est un c'est
un poste 4 qui est capable d'écarter le
jeu d'offrir du spacing mais aussi qui
est assez qui est assez polyvalent j
est-ce que toi ça te va ou tu as envie
de nous raconter qu'il met des des gros
pouup et qu'il initie du jeu est-ce que
c'est Pascal siakam 2.0 pas du tout je
je suis 100 % d'accord avec
ok bah écoutez voilà vous avez
maintenant des billes pour voir si ça
peut vous intéresser pour votre équipe
NBA ou pas et puis pour du coup nous
nous insulter d'ici 3 4 avec grand
plaisir on va aller dans le détail on va
commencer par par apprendre un peu plus
du garçon sa vie privée sa biographie
Manu qu'est-ce que tu peux nous dire sur
sur kg Evans bah rapidement c'est un un
monsieur qui est né en 2004 en aût 2004
donc 19 ans eu pour c'est quelqu'un qui
aurait pu être drafté l'année dernière
finalement sur la classe d'âge mais aux
États-Unis c'est un peu plus différent
né à Baltimore au Maryland côest et euh
particularité c'est qu'il a un papa qui
a joué au en collège aussi à George
Washington il a un cousin T qui joue lui
actuellement aussi en en NCA à à USC
upstate avant il a transféré de San
Diego state donc voilà c'est une famille
quand même assez assez basket il a fait
son cursus High School en partie à à
monteverd Academie où où là-bas il a
gagné les titres titres nationaux High
School avec il a d il a dû jouer avec
Kade
avec euh comment il s'appelle
ouais dCK whiteited voilà c'est cette
génération là et donc il a il a il joue
maintenant pour pour Orgon donc il est
il est freschman il il commence à
carburer plutôt pas mal en ce moment sur
les sur les match de conférence
ouais donc encore encore un gros
prospect qui allait s'enterrer dans la
PCT to et dans le simtier et Oregon
c'est une passe toute trouvée pour pour
jus euh toi qui défends à la conf
champions en tout cas ce qu'il en reste
qu'est-ce que tu peux nous dire sur sur
quemi en terme de de mensuration
physique l'athlète
rapidement 2
M6 ce jeune 2 M6 moi j'ai 90 kg euh
elle a alors j'ai trouvé différents
styles pour son son envergure euh autour
de 2,10 je pense si je dis pas de
bêtises 2,10 2,13 euh qu'est-ce qu'on
peut dire de son physique c'est un jeune
qui était comment dire qui court qui
court pas mal qui se déplace plutôt bien
nord- sudud
euh c'est pas comment dire l'athlète du
siècle il va pas voler au-dessus de de
l'anneau péter des dunks à TVA et c'est
pas et puis visuellement c'est pas un
gamin qui a beaucoup de puissance comme
ça euh pas forcément des épaules très
larges voilà pour le un un visuel rapide
de de son physique euh voilà enfin long
segment plutôt léger plutôt grand et
assez agile pour se déplacer sans avoir
une vitesse hornant
ouais c'est un garçon qui euh qui on le
voit quand même un petit peu évoluer
depuis depuis le lycée je trouve que
augon l' l'a pas mal renforcé
physiquement donc ça peut être un axe de
développement on va aller voir ça un
petit peu après pour restit sur le sur
les ducs sur les fighting ducs avec le
l'un des meilleurs parquets de toute la
NCA dans des PL aux épileptiques euh
comment ça joue en gros les les ducs et
il y a quoi comme spacing il y a quoi
comme niveau de de joueur à côté de lui
euh alors ça a été une année compliquée
il faut que je commence par ça euh des
blessés au début d'autres blessés au
milieu là ça revient un petit peu euh
alors c'est c'est coaché par man qui est
là depuis 14 ans au à Oregon qui a vu
passer pas mal de joueurs qui l' quand
même B
bbonard j'en avais un autre là récemment
jeppelle
plus voilà c'est ça qui avait 28 ans
mais qui était prêt joueur ouais et donc
le le
jeu bon c'est Altman il fait appel
souvent à des seniors REC beaucoup de de
senior ces dernières années pour
encadrer son équipe alors ça veut dire
que souvent les les jeunes ont un temps
de jeu au début limité eTTH et puis il
les développe petit à petit je dirais
que ça comme ça l'année dernière ça a
pas trop marché pour where moi je suis
pas sûr qu'on estit le le fin mot de
l'histoire pourquoi est-ce qu'il a
pourquoi est-ce que l'année de de ce
jeune n'a pas n'a pas été performante
comme il aurait voulu et qu'il a dû
changer
d'équipe C Ann par tu parles du coup de
pour les pour les gens qui écoutent tu
as dire rapidement k on a déjà fait un
podcast donc allez l'écouter qui a fait
une première année Oregon et qui est
parti à Indiana et qui l' Indiana ouais
et qui qui s'est mieux développé dans
son jeu Indiana
euh le le donc il est entouré par des
par des arrières par des gue vétéran au
début de l'année euh des ailiers costau
et il débutait euh au poste 4 avec un
pivot euh enfal Danté qui est un joueur
dont on ne saura jamais s'il peut faire
une année entière non il les fait pas il
fait pas d'année entière n il a été
blessé encore une fois comme chaque
année depuis 4 ou 5 ans je pense une
grosse partie de la saison qui a un
pivot qui est très costaud très puissant
euh qui peut être très spectaculaire euh
mais voilà au bout d'un match il s'est
blessé et euh du coup il a été obligé de
de prendre la place de numéro 5 est-ce
que c'est un jeu qui est enfin pour le
spacing c'est moi je dirais qu'il y a
pas vraiment de de spécialiste du shoot
même s'il y a des même s'il y a des
joueurs qui shootent avec des bons
pourcentages voilà je pense pas que les
les ce soit des tous les arrières qui
jouent avec lui soi des spécialistes au
shoot au niveau du guardpl c'était assez
moyen en début d'année quand c'était
Barthelemy belemi qui qui menait le jeu
et là ça va beaucoup mieux avec alors là
je vais avoir du mal à prononcer son nom
il va falloir mer shell stat j'espère
que ça va on va l'appeler le le si
américain de de Thomas breton qui est
dans notre équipe en verers franchement
les gars j'ai rencontré Thomas en vrai
quand on a fait le la la soirée draft
all a regarder le replay en first team
et allit regarder le beau gosse aussi
qui est Jackson shulstud et il y a une
vraie siminitude donc on va lui lui
espérer le le même
succès mais voilà c'est notre Jackson
c'est notre Thomas version version Ron
donc voilà pour aller vite il a il a
quand même donné une autre allure à
l'attaque de au guardpl
d'Oregon il a un jeu il est c'est un
joueur très vif qui sait qui a plus
comment dire de de skills de de guardpl
que
bartelemi est-ce que ça te suffit à
parfait franchement moi tout me va tu
sais moi je ne suis que là je ne suis
qu'en qu'en spectateur j'ai mon petit
pop-corn et je déguste vos paroles donc
pour une fois je me repose un peu plus
euh on a parlé du coup du style de jeu
desdux on a vu un petit peu le le G on a
parlé du physique eu vous avez dit en
début de d'émission intérieure qui peut
écarter le jeu est-ce que c'est un de
ces points forts actuellement est-ce que
c'est un axe de développement si je vous
devaz donner une point enfin un point
clé pour l'entré en NBA un vrai point
fort Manu sur quoi tu iris en premier
moi c'est je veux pas aller sur jeis sur
plusieurs choses mais c'est la
polyvalence pour moi ce qui ce qui me
fait l'acheter c'est c'est que c'est un
joueur un peu à la à la à la jar Welker
l'année dernière qui est maintenant au
per c'est quelqu'un qui peut contrer qui
peut passer qui peut prendre des Herbon
et qui peut scorer donc c'est vraiment
ça moi que j'achète c'est c'est donc
quelqu'un un rle Player qui va qui va
qui va être plus ou moins plus gameplay
quoi que tu fasses skel stick qu'importe
le style de jeu que tuas et moi c'est
vraiment ça que j'achète aujourd'hui
pour donner un petit peu les stats qui
qui vont compléter dans le profil on est
à 8 points 5 rebonds de passes alors sur
le temps de jeu c'est 22 minutes sachant
qu'il y a des hauts et des bas comme Jul
a dit beaucoup de blessures donc en gros
les jeunes ils prennent ce qui reste il
y avait pas infalid denté et Beatle donc
il avait pu beaucoup jouer la Danté
revient donc il joue un peu moins ce qui
est très intéressant dans la polyvalence
comme tu le dis c'est le en défensive si
on peut un peu développer là-dessus Manu
1,3 bloc 1,6 steills 5,4 bonds au global
c'est un joueur que tu vois être aussi
polyvalent dans la défense
ouais malgré ça le petit point faible ça
va -être sa taille et sur sur qui il va
pouvoir défendre parce que il a quand
même des gogotes et les il a pas
forcément la taille d'un intérieur donc
est-ce faud peut-être trouver trouver ça
l'alchimie qu'il faut pour
pas forcément le cacher parce que c'est
un un joueur qui est capable de de
défendre et de de se fcher sur du pick
and R notamment il il a beaucoup de
séquences notamment au début d'année où
où il switch sur les pick and roll il
garde vraiment bien les arrières qu'on
qu'on la balle en main donc moi je
trouve que j'ai pas forcément
d'inquiétude là-dessus honnêtement sur
sur sa capacité à défendre ou peut-être
plus sur les les les les gros en soi les
les les Big Man bien balaise mais mais
mais autrement je mais je je sais pas
forcément d' inquiétude je pense aussi
que le corps va s'élargir donc à terme
je ça ça va être la clé pour moi cette
polyvalence que ce soit défensive ouou
offensive j'ai pas de j'ai pas trop
d'inquiétude là aujourd'hui sur ça j
déjà est-ce que toi tu es d'accord avec
ça et est-ce que tu as un autre point
fort assez évident qui te qui te vient
en
tête c'est exactement ce que j'avais
noté c'était moi mon point fort c'était
la
polyvalence au début et euh
c'est vrai que il est il est assez il
s'est adapté en fait au rôle qu'on lui a
donné aux différents rôles qu'on lui a
donné cette année donc plutôt un 4atre
au début qui qui allait switcher et puis
euh là il a il a défendu beaucoup de
poste 5 avant le retour de Danté euh il
a il a été plutôt bon il a je l'ai vu
encaer des chocs bien costauds même si
c'est on sent que c'est pas sa ça peut
pas être sa spécialité mais il a pris
des gros babars dans dans le coffre et
il est pas ridicule
euh et puis ce qui est assez bluffant
c'est la façon dont il arrive à piquer
des ballons euh il a il a une vivacité
il arrive à se placer euh à voir très
vite où vont être les passes et euh il
est capable en dans certains matchs de
piquer trois quatre ballons comme ça en
très peu de temps euh qu qu j'exagère
mais il a il a T des passages où il va
sentir vraiment les les passes il va
faire une série d'interceptions c'est
vraiment un joueur en défense qui qui et
c'est là où je voulais en venir qui
s'est vraiment adapté et je pense que ça
c'est un autre un autre facteur assez
important je trouve chez lui auelà il y
a sa polyvalence qui permet de faire pas
mal de choses en attaque et en défense
là on parle de la défense il y a aussi
son adaptation aux différents rôles
qu'on lui a donné il arrivé avec un une
étiquette five star de futur shooter à
TR points niau de C 2 ma 6 qui pouvait
courir avec le ballon et puis on a vu
aussi autre chose quoi on a vu un début
d'année un peu compliqué puis après on a
vu autre chose d'autres facettes de son
jeu très intéressant donc adaptation je
dirais polyvalence et adaptation ouais
je vous rejoins totalement là-dessus
c'est un joueur qui en High School il
faisait 85 kg il prenait il posait la
balle un peu au sol il prenait des
pullup là il y a plus 10 kg déjà et un
vrai rôle de mettre des écrans des
tampons des car de jeu de faire tout
bien et comme vous l'avez dit un
placement défensif vraiment très
impressionnant pour son âge avec le peu
de répétition qui il a eu euh toujours
bien placé dans l'aide toujours la bonne
lecture du jeu rattrape vite euh pour
pour fermer sur les tireurs donc moi je
suis vraiment très surpris par cet
aspect là de son jeu et c'est dans un
contexte je vous l'avais dit collectif
où il y a eu beaucoup de modifications
d'être aussi en place pour un mec de 19
ans c'est encore une fois impressionnant
et oui c'est une ça lui permet d'avoir
des minutes directement peut-être au
niveau supérieur par par ce côtélà si
vous deviez développer une chose chez ce
garçon pour faire passer
de voilà d'un d'un prospect moyen
intéressant à un vrai mec qui peut être
five stars comme on en parle ce soir et
viser un top 20 lot tripic sur quoi vous
iriez je vais commencer avec Manu h la
moi la plus grosse chose pour entrer
dans le basket d'aujourd'hui c'est une
amélioration au tir extérieur m licence
extérieur parce que actuellement il est
à moins de 30 25 % à TR points sur un
peu moins de trois tentatives par match
donc c'est assez limité on va dire pour
avoir un vrai rôle mais le le fait qu'il
shoot à 82 % au lancer
franc me laisse penser que il y a une
progression possible là là-dessus parce
que ça veut dire que on le répète à
quasiment à chaque podcast je pense mais
ça veut dire qu'il a déjà sa gestuelle
en fait il a déjà son tir qui est qui
est cadré donc ça il le maîtrise et ça
rentre dedans donc ça veut dire que il
aura pas forcément de difficulté à
sécter un peu plus avec le temps donc
moi je c'est vraiment sur ça que
j'acerai sur sur les premières semaines
les premiers mois en NBA ouais
clairement je regardais là un petit peu
au niveau au niveau lycéen au niveau du
shoot à 3 point on était effectivement
dans ces dans ces 34 % 33 % qui sont pas
encore suffisants pour être un vrai vrai
stretch for vra strch F mais il y avait
une belle efficacité au lancer franc et
sur le mid dististance il a plus de 45 %
donc ça c'est aussi un signe intéressant
pour pour développer du tir
derrière Julien toi est-ce que c'est
aussi pour toi l'axe prioritaire de
développement de quem EV junior le le
shoot
extérieur oui je pense parce qu' je vois
pas quel autre rôle on pourrait lui
donner en fait tu vois
donc le rôle qu'il aurait
c'est d'être un défonur sur des sur des
postes un petit peu variés et et et
d'écarter le jeu avec son shoot je vois
pas trop ce qu'on peut lui dire il shoot
à il prend que des à trois points il
prend que des des shoots qui sont issus
d'une passe c'est que du qu shoot et
comme disait Manu le le lancer franc
quand on voit shoter ce lancer France
c'est hyper rassurant parce qu'il a il a
un geste très fluide en fait très fluide
très compact et et à trois point ça
rentre pas mais il continueent à les
prendre ça je trouve ça assez rassurant
il prend beaucoup il a un gros volume de
de tir même si la réussite est un peu
clata quoi
donc ça me para en fait les les les
points qu'on aborde c'est c'est vraiment
ça ça paraît très évident quand on le
voit quoi
ça là le shoot il faut qu'il le
développe et puis il a pour pour
développer dans le tir moi je suis
complètement d'accord avec ce que vous
dites là mais on a deux types de tir
pour moi on a le le corner dans le fin
de chaîne et on a du en pop euh où il va
pouvoir poser l'écran est-ce que
pourtailler un petit peu son jeu parce
qu'on a on a été très comment dire é es
très dans le Global est-ce que vous
aimez ça sa pose d'écran est-ce que vous
aimez aussi le côté qu'on pourra lui
donner du coup dans le rô dans la dans
la passe sur le short troll dans cette
polyvalence là et sa finition au panier
Manu sur sur la pause d'écran moi je
trouve qu'il a encore cette cette
fébrilité il est pas euh
compact on va dire il reste pas
forcément en place et il tient pas
forcément le si l'adversaire lui lui
fonce un peu dedans il a pas forcément
cette capacité à tenir sur ces appuis
donc c'est peut-être ça un peu à à
bouger mais après la capacité à pop et à
et à rouler c'est c'est super
intéressant et je je trouve que ça lui
apporte aussi une variante et un plus
sur ce qu'on qu'on ce qu'on dit et le
sur sur la passe c'est intéressant parce
que moi je trouve que c'est un passeur
assez sous côté dans dans son jeu c'est
c'est c'est que une virgule passe
décisive par match cette année mais en
en fait il est capable de de les de les
faire bien et au bon moment et c'est
déjà ce qu'on ce qu'on avait pu
apercevoir en High School moi c'est
vraiment ce qui m'avait marqué quand il
était à Monteverde c'est c'est vraiment
cette capacité à à bien diriger le jeu à
bien trouver les les les passes
intéressantes que ce soit extérieur ou
ou intérieur sur du Rao ou du short roll
comme ça je trouve qu'on on en on en
parle pas suffisamment de cette capacité
là qui qu' l' bien
passé tout à fait d'accord avec ça
vraiment et et euh et en plus on l'util
le coach l'utilise il il a souvent la
balle en tête de raquette euh soit pour
du handof soit pour décider de de faire
des passes alors souvent c'est des
passes qui viennent d'une de d'un
système j'ai l'impression donc euh il
sait à peu près où vont passer les gars
où où ils vont se placer mais les balles
ils arrivent dans la main euh pour des
tirs à trois points et les cuts il les
il les voit bien aussi fait des très
belles passes sur les cuts c'est c'est
vraiment je trouve une qualité qu'il a
aussi tout à fait d'accord
ouais donc c'est un joueur qui va avoir
quand même de la de la variété de la
polyvalence offensive qui va pouvoir
offrir des espaces alors d'autant plus
quand il pourra tirer dans le dans le
pop mais rien que sur sur pit and roll
avec sur peut-être un poste 4 et un un
Forur de jeu il pourra déjà donner une
une menace dans l' etfire la la la bonne
la bonne transition euh si on est dans
le jeu de la comparaison parce qu'en NBA
a quelques profils qui ressemblent
est-ce qu'il y a des mecs comme ça qui
qui vous font penser à quem events
junior ou bien il y avait pe-être des
prospects qui vous faisent penser à
commivan junior et qui ont réussi ou
pas alors moi je suis je me suis bien
pris la tête sur la question en fait je
dis à chaque fois c'est catastrophique
en fait j'essayé de faerer des gars de
de sa taille qui justement étaiit
qui était polyvalent et qui euh et qui
se sont adaptés à différentes situations
tu vois vraiment pour reprendre les
qualités qu'on qu'on a dit et euh bon
j'ai que des comparaisons kata quoi tu
vois j'avais noté si tu veux je te dis
ce que j'ai j'avais noté l'i John
Collins alors là vous êtes catastrophé
tous les deux parce que vous voyez pas
du tout le rapport euh non il a pas du
tout les mêmes qualités physique mais ce
gars on lui a demandé tout d'un coup de
de de de de sortir et de shoter à trois
points par exemple tu vois c'est c'est
dans cet esprit là que j'avais jeavais
je l'avais vu tu vois et euh et là il
est à
il joue autrement donc c'est un gars
j'ai l'impression qu' arrive à s'adapter
c'est plus là-dedans que je le voyais
voilà ouais je pas c'estata c'est je
comm
compar y a moins de verticalité mais je
vois ce que tu veux dire dans le dans le
rôle offensif Manu toi-ce qu'il a un
autre nom qui trop bien après je vous
dirai les les deux gars que j'ai noté de
mon côté ben moi je vais je vaouis
rebondir sur ce qu'avait dire un
commentate sur un sur un match où il le
comparait à Chris
Bosch oui bon ben voilà là je tombe plus
de ma
cha mais je parle pas du je parle pas du
du joueur en en tant que tel du jeu de
Chris Bosch mais ou plus sur ce côté
Miami où où il était devenu cette
troisème option capable de tout faire et
qui s'adaptait à tout voilà jeu Lestra
et il était juste exceptionnel après
Chris Bosch était beaucoup plus beaucoup
plus grand il lu rend quasiment 10
cm il avait beaucoup plus de tirs aussi
et beaucoup moins cette capacité à à
switcher tout ça mais dans dans ce rôle
là de de Miami où il était cette 3è 4e
option derrière les les le monstre de
tête bah je je je je je vois un peu ce
que ce qu'il voulait dire moi je le con
pas au joueur en tant que tel parce que
il ressemble pas du tout dans le jeu ni
dans la morphologie mais dans dans ce
rôle là qu'il avait à Miami de de ce
quatre fuyant benah je je c'est plus ce
ce rôle là moi dans lequel je vais le je
vais le mettre en terme de comparaison
c'est compliqué comme il est assez
polyvalent finalement il fait pas il y a
moi je vois pas comme ça de de post 4
qui qui me viennent en tête capable de
plus ou moins tout faire comme ça bah je
t'en propose je t'en propose deux et
vous me dites ce que vous en pensez je
regardé dans le dans les dimensions et
et dans les statistiques euh il y a gr
Williams que j'aimais bien euh alors gr
Williams sortit de Tennesse dont on va
parler dans un autre podcast comme fac
mais qui avait beaucoup plus de maturité
physique mais on a dit développement du
direct défenseur aussi euh je trouve au
mêmegein à la sortie parce qu'il avait 3
ans de fac mais je suis d'accord faut
qu'il prenne tu vois que s'il passe la
barre des 105 110 kg avec le shoot à
tris points qui était pas encore là à
Tennesse et qu'on a découvert à Boston
dans les corners
euh ce serait une une projection quand
même assez idéale pour pour notre ami
Kem V sans être non plus surréaliste et
PJ Washington dans la comparaison encore
un peu fin au
niveau au niveau NCA qui choait pas très
bien à la fac et qui ensuite a développé
ça maintenant et qui au côté de de
Charlotte enfin du côté de Charlotte
même si le contexte collectif et les
résultats sont pas là et tu un joueur
qui est quand même assez intéressant
ouais je comprends mais tu on encore on
est encore dans le dans l'entre deux
parce que grand Williams c'est quand
même bien plus petit et pu Washington
est un peu plus grand que lui je pense
non alors grand Willams plus petit ouais
je bien de croire je crois qu'il a 203
grand et peut-être c'est 98 tu vois
ouais c'est possible c'était un gros
tank et PJ watch faut faut voir mais
c'est vraiment dans ce profil de P watch
de
Washington j'ai bien le côté le je vois
ce que tu veux dire sur le côté de
kentuki O où il y avait un peu des
préisses de tout oua aprs j'ai pas trop
regardé à au Hornets donc je peux pas
trop en même temps ça brûle un peu les
yeux si on a des des copains des Hornets
je suis désolé bon quand la méobo est
pas là les les fait marquant de l'équipe
c'est que leur joueurfin leur deuxième
joueur farm est des des droites à sa
femme et à ses gosses donc il y a mieux
il y a mieux clairement euh pour alors
peut-être j'ai peut-être joueur chinois
là Kyle Anderson qui joue c'est ça il
chinois donc après Kyle Anderson c
vraent plus un meneur et en arrière tu
oui voilà voilà mais exceptionnel
défenseur aussi sur certaines périodes
et en fait c'est c'est des joueurs très
singuliers en fait dans leur ouais c'est
ça c'est là on va plus comme disent les
Américains c'est du shade of to tu as
pas un joueur qui qui ressemble en fait
c'est c'est vraiment un mix de de
plusieurs
exactement rend j'ai un nom qui me vient
en tête qui est complètement à l'opposé
en terme de jeu aussi et de physique
c'est j Kim noir qui était capable de
passer de d'être super fort sur les pics
de de défendre comme un monstre
quasiment toutes les positions lui
atendra jamais ce ce ce niveaulà
défensivement je pense mais tu tu vois
c'était vraiment ce ce gars pareil qui
pouvait à l'époque à Chicago se se
greffer à tout toute les situation il
était il était devenu indispensable à
cette équipe là et c'est pareil c'était
un mec un 3e 4e option derrière les rose
Butler Boer l holdeng et je moi c'est
c'est un peu ce ce r que je je lui vois
c'est vraiment un cas qui va être qui va
devenir ultra ultra euh obligatoire dans
son équipe pour performer que ça tourne
tu vois il il va faire une une carrière
à à 10 points rebonds de contre mais
c'est un gars qui va faire 15 ans NBA
sur les mêmes statistiques du coup la
tradition est toute
trouvé un garçon à 10 points 8 rebonds
de contre on lui espère et peut-être une
style 1,5 style vous l'achetez dans
cette draft d'autant plus mais vous
l'achetez où et est-ce que vous y croyez
ou pas
j moi j'y crois je crois parce que voilà
c'est un joueur très spécial très
singulier je pense qu'il va trouver est
quelqu'un qui va il y a un frontofice
qui va l'aimer donc il va être pris euh
donc moi je le je le verraz bien en
vraiment euh en deuxème partie de
premier tour voilà autour de entre je
sais pas deème partie pas entre 20 et 30
quoi voilà ok Manu
ouais moi je je pense en fait c'est le
rle player parfait quasiment qui qui
aujourd'hui est moyen partout mais qui
peut être très très bon partout très
prochainement s'il a dans le bon
contexte sur mon premier bord je l'avais
34 et sur le deuxème je l'ai monté 23
donc c'est saeson là fin de 2è fin de
premier fin de premier tour ok ouais Mo
il est après la loterie quoi entre entre
20 et
35 c'est ça moi je l'ai je l'ai pareil
je l'ai de la 20e place et euh et j'y
crois j'y crois aussi je je me dis que
le tir le tir ça va aller la défense
elle est vraiment très très bonne dans
tous les contextes donc je je je pense
que ce jeune garçon peut faire une vraie
belle carrière NBA donc voilà je vais
l'acheter au même niveau et euh et en
lui souhaitant le meilleur bon ben
écoutez les gars c'était très très cool
j'espère que que vous avez passé un bon
moment en notre compagnie ceux qui ont
écouté ce podcast on se retrouve très
bientôt pour un nouvel épisode euh
envergure que ce soit un five stars
underdgs n'hésitez pas à partager
n'hésitez pas à nous laisser votre avis
n'hésitez pas aussi à donner vos vos
bord de façon globale et et à à
interagir avec nous sur toute notre
plateformes que ce soit Twitter que ce
soit sur le site que ce soit dans les
commentaires YouTube ou en stream on est
là pour vous des gros bisous et merci
les gars d'avoir fait ce ce tournage
avec moi ciao bye
bye